Demi's one of my closest friends in the
world you know I'm here for her and et
was with Nick Jonas on Wednesday in New
York City at the launch party for his
new line of headphones and speakers with
Altec Lansing the 23 year old singer
opened up about his close pals Demi
Lovato and Wilmer Valderrama and
revealed they're doing just fine post
splits I built an amazing friendship
with Wilmer over the years and I have so
much love for him Demi is one of my
closest friends in the world you know
I'm here for her and for both of them
really I think that I'm just thrilled to
be able to do this tour with her and I
think it's probably the best timing for
everybody up next Nick and Demi will hit
the road together for their future now
tour
he's keeping real busy with his TV show
Kingdom new movie goat opposite James
Franco and a new album called last year
was complicated
do
clubs
thankfully he said 2016 has been much
smoother proud of my work and extending
to other areas of entertainment as well
beyond just the music I would say this
year is less complicated and kind of
amazing